hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and yesterday i put a video out on my
youtube channel
where i literally spontaneously left my
home
went to aisle loans with no money and to
on a mission to try and help a man
called david become financially free
the video went out yesterday it's a
two-part series so the next part is
going to be coming out
on tuesday next week however i thought
i'd introduce
on youtube in my house mr david eckles
hello you're a celebrity now then
brother yeah it's taking off really good
really happy with the
concert can you believe it's had 7.6 000
views overnight i can't believe that
that's just taken off more than what i
thought i thought maybe
2000 but this has exploded so it really
has and your phone is blowing right now
with congratulation messages and stuff
like that but i really thought it'd be
nice to just talk to you about what
happened yesterday on the video
we can even read some comments and and
give some thoughts but i don't want to
spoil anything either
so i i wanna i don't want this to be a
spoiler because the obviously part two
is coming out next week yeah
so we can only talk about what happened
yesterday
by the way guys if you've not watched
yesterday's video
it was it was a good bit of fun it was a
good bit
so firstly why don't you just in your
words what what happened
like what happened yesterday oh
yesterday was it was mad
basically i've got so many messages
coming in i can't believe the amount of
support
uh both from ireland england everywhere
and it's uh
it's really taken off but what happened
okay i say yesterday
from your perspective because the video
was kind of shown from my perspective
like you know i'm leaving england to go
to ireland from my perspective
from your perspective when i said to you
because it was quite last minute
i know you you you're in the eviction
yes and you knew i was going to be
coming at some point
but it was like oh i'm coming you know
in a couple days i think it was a couple
days notice where i was like
i'm definitely coming out yeah in two
days um like what was going on in your
head and
did you know i was definitely coming i
mean you'd see like what what was
happening from your body
what it is i didn't realize your comment
you know you give me a call
so quick to say david i'm gonna be there
sunday night and
yeah it kind of caught me on the hop but
it was a good thing because uh
you know i didn't get much time to think
everything was raw from the start
and i was just excited because that is
life changing you know
i knew it was gonna be but it didn't
realize how good it actually
turned out to be so so i got to your i
got to the airport yeah and you were
there
yeah at the airport now one of the crazy
things because there's a lot of people
in the comments talking about
because i put the caption as financial
freedom challenge in ireland
and there's people going crazy like in
the comments saying you know it's not
ireland it's northern ireland
but it you really do live in ireland i
do yes but i'm
20 minutes from northern ireland so it's
it's in the north of ireland but it's
uh so you're in the north of ireland but
not in northern ireland in the republic
right however the deal that we got
was just outside of north of ireland
actually in northern ireland in derry
yes yeah so talk a bit about where you
live where we got the deal and why we
chose to go to
derry yeah for our first rental event
deal basically dairy is the closest city
to where i live so it's only like
20 30 minutes and we've been down there
it's if i when i move back home it's
basically
it's i can self-manage the property as
it's only 30 minutes
i got we got the rent to rent it's you
know it's close
it's a good property i know the area i
know the market
and it's that's why you went for dairy
city basically now on the documentary
yesterday
the way it ended was like we've got the
rent to rent
however we need to get the money for it
and it was a bit early days you haven't
got the keys for it
so people don't know exactly what's
going to happen what's coming however
i guess a slight spoiler alert you did
get that deal right i got to do
yeah you got the deal um and that was
just the first of many deals that you
went on to get
so talk to me about that particular deal
because that's the one that everyone
knows
yeah um i mean i've just literally been
speaking to the to the agent today he
just messaged me saying happy st
patrick's day which is great at the same
packaging stage today
um which is an irish thing but talk to
me about the deal
how we got it what the figures are run
through the details of that particular
deal
yeah that tale went down to the first
agent and
it only had one property that wasn't let
out by
students so um then it was only property
with a hmo license
so that's what we needed to make money
you need basically five bedrooms to
really make the money and it was
vacant so all right the landlord's tired
the property's not rented out i
i secured that property for 650 pound a
month
and now the the agent's going crazy i
know it makes you inside oh they didn't
want to say
i got a message to say that basically
i robbed the dealer because it's seen on
the figures that
we're saying if we can get it for seven
seven five it's going to be a great deal
just about eight no no yeah i think 775
would have been high it just in case
he's watching them
you know 705 would have been a bit high
listen he's happy he got what he you
know we
and again that's the thing in business
if you say to someone what's the lowest
you can accept and still live with
yeah the bottom line is that's what
they're happy with business is about
win-win
so so so that and the really interesting
thing is as well
is i've just done the financial freedom
challenge with lawton
in manchester we could not get a rent to
rent bro
yeah this is the thing i think northern
ireland is a brilliant market
and a lot of people think does your
tactics work there you know they're very
skeptical because there's no right move
and they do work here and the agents i
think here there are a lot of people
doing your training they're ringing for
rent to rent daily sourcing nobody is
doing it back there
and when we went there they said what do
you mean rent to rent
yeah we explained it and they're like
well here's a property does it suit you
so i'm getting 6 50 am i'm paying 650 a
month for that and that's going to begin
i estimated about 17 1800 pound
for the challenges yeah and we'll talk
about what what's going on with that
deal now because i know at the moment
it is fully talented at the moment which
we'll talk about but i think something
really interesting
in england which is where i live
everybody says
oh maybe it's oversaturated because
everyone's doing it in england
in other parts of the world people go
does it i must only work in england
because everyone's doing it in england
and actually i think the truth is you
just have to take
what country you're in what place you're
in
and flip the cards take the cards you've
got flip the cards
the grass is always greener on the other
side and it's so easy to come with
excuses but the reason i love doing
financial freedom challenges across the
world i've done one now in america
now i've been i've gone to ireland is
because
i think that the strategies just
generally work everywhere
i think it's just a case of finding out
the niche and
and in in manchester we couldn't i
couldn't get a rent to it i failed
but then when we went to ireland okay
the border back and forth
yeah right but but but we got one
literally i'm sure that was like the
first
or second agent that we went into the
first agent
yeah because literally we went in there
i know there
it's a student market area so i said
right this is the street
where all the students want to be yeah
this was the only agent on that street
so
you said why don't you just go into the
agents and at first it was so awkward
because it was
with the lockdown yeah and and and it
was like oh you only allowed one person
in and we had me
you the videographer you know and it was
just a bit but but but the bottom line
is
we went in we explained what the
proposition is and we got a rent to rent
deal within
day one yes i know that it is so easy as
you
as you talked about if you can implement
that strategy
taking the character dealt it does work
anywhere and
uh we done that in first agent we got
the rent to rent so they do work your
strategies work
everywhere and what's happening now with
the rent to win
because in fact before you answer that
question
if we got in at such a good time because
the whole student thing
yes and again we flipped the cards
right we're in the middle of a lockdown
and and it's like okay well we're in the
middle of a lockdown and the student
market's not popping right now and this
is pretty much a student area only
what a terrible time to do rent to rent
how did we flip the cards
so we took advantage of that you know
basically that property was laying
vacant i think 11 months
with the covert so we took advantage you
said let's
put in a short term let get it let
until september and then put the
students in and then we're gonna
that's we're gonna make the money then
from september so it's about securing
the property now
yeah and that is fully tenanted but you
stick it on airbnb
yes it's it's and you've got it's fully
booked out until
it's fully booked out until the end of
august middle of august sorry that's
incredible
yeah this is incredible so it's fully
booked out until the end of
august but you're but but but what
you're thinking is
in september you're or probably in
august you can start advertising it
you get students in september and keep
the property for
for three years make some make some
money on it yeah
boom shaka nice little rental rent what
what what did you learn
from the whole experience the whole
experience is
just take advantage of what you can do
now at the moment so
okay it's during the pandemic how can i
make this
work and if we want to get a rent around
people's like well why don't we wait to
august
but you won't get student lots in august
so we took advantage now
yeah make the best of it it's fully
booked out making a little bit of money
but i'm really going to make the money
in september yeah
about everything else it's just the
deals are there in front to speak to
agents you said just have the
relationship
and agents are actually ringing me
giving me deals
even today so okay let's have a quick
look at some of these comments
because are there any are there any
comments that stood out to you that you
you remember
oh have a look on your phone i'll have a
look on my phone we're gonna be
responding to comments from the
financial freedom challenge okay now
it's at 7.8 000. it's going up literally
100 views
i mean i'm surprised at how well the
views have gone to be honest
um okay samuel's enthusiasm gets me
excited i'm not in the property business
but i've copied his attitude and i'm
doing well
in my agency business that's good did
you see the one guy that
that dissed you that said that you're
always going to get that too
there was the one guy that said thank
god for samuel's energy because david's
energy was terrible
did you see that one did you read the
end of that comment no read it read it
to me
hold on you can read it oh here we go
that's why i love the video they get
better and better
but thank god for samuel's energy
david's
put me to sleep guy needs a kick up the
ass i didn't feel like he contributed
anything so far he could definitely do
with training and
red bull right why what at the end of
the comments say
london dairy looks a difficult task
exactly because
it's back to this dairy london dairy
yeah that's where you get dissed
you know it's uh it's a political thing
so you think that him saying that you
had no energy yeah and you need red bull
was nothing to do with the fact that you
put him to sleep and everything to do
with a political thing
i could have put him to sleep
[Laughter]
you won't say that i can't afford a
mistake but it's
why would i say londonderry okay i don't
know talk to me about the whole beef
between dairy
what is that it's the same thing it's
just um i think it's a religious thing
both people say dairy some people say
londonderry
and some people take it personally and
if you
say dairy well you're going to get abuse
so yeah so that's why that was
maintained in the end of the comments
see i did a bit of research on this
whole dairy versus londonderry thing
and my understanding is that the actual
name
the technical name is londonderry yeah
but then
some of the folks in the area that don't
particularly like england don't like the
fact that it's got london in the name so
they dropped the london and now
just call it derry and then there's a
bit of some people call it dairy some
people call it london dairy yeah
is that right or is that is that oh yeah
it's uh i don't i think no
uh years ago it was taken more
personally now people just get on with
it you know it's the same place
but yeah just two different names right
do people in
ireland like people from england yes
do they honestly i found that everybody
was really friendly
you know what i think the media have got
a bad perspective
it's not like that at all the market's
booming people love each other there you
know
it's it's not what it's painted to be
okay what about this guy
this is um shahara he says
avoid ireland a corrupted land
leading in drug distribution dealers
users across
europe crime gangs very high
accommodation problems
homelessness addictions abuses some
dishonest people
leaders not enough policing security in
dublin
some areas are unsafe do your research
many irish people
irish leaders just don't care unwilling
to act or resolve issues avoid avoid
avoid what do you think of that
political leaders i agree but you know
they don't do enough for the people but
the rest is just uh
i don't know what planet the thing is a
lot of what he's saying is he's saying
that it's
all that some people are that bad and
some but that's the case anyway wherever
you go there's going to be good people
than bad people
he says a corrupted land i mean that's a
bit harsh
it's not the people there as you've seen
yourself it's really nice they're
forthcoming they're friendly
you know it's it's not the thought yeah
um north west warriors awesome
undercover millionaire got a team up
with
grant cardone um brian morgan
so he's just he's just like put a little
hold on we could pay tomorrow
what was going through your head when i
said we could pay tomorrow for this
rental rate
i was like you're putting the pressure
on me because financially uh
it wasn't a it wasn't a good move there
okay we tried to secure it but
i think was trying to delay it and delay
uh pierce
yeah for a few days and he says we could
pay tomorrow and i was like
we haven't even got money yeah so it was
uh
it puts the pressure on basically and
it's a
middle worker basically your ass off for
the next few days
um somebody says why is samuel always
naked in these challenges
i know i agree i think it's because
well i i think it's because i don't know
pav you might want to best answer in
that one am i always naked in these
documentaries you are what you are you
know
it's not nothing staged nothing's you
just start with your
and you just uh here's the thing right
some of the magic that happens
is late at night yeah okay because
you've been putting office forward and
you're waiting on money coming in
and sometimes it's at night and after
about 8 p.m
once dinner's done and stuff like that i
do like to be a bit more casual maybe my
dressing gown or whatever i feel
comfortable
and then suddenly something magical
starts happening i'm oh
and then pav is there filming i'm not
going to go get changed just for the
cameras right i'm just like oh wow oh
the money's just coming in
and it's late or it's early and and it
just happens to be that sometimes that
happens when i'm not dressed
appropriately
but then you know it'll be it'll be
selfish of me to remove it from the
documentary
just because i'm not just appropriately
so yeah that is great because you are so
genuine and everything you did is honest
and not there and it's not as i say not
nothing stage and that's why
as you said deals come in late at night
and
early in the morning maybe you've got
emails and
yes it is what it is it's
commented he said yes david um i think i
got a bit of a beast as well because we
put the flag wrong we're supposed to put
the irish flag
but then we put another flag on it on on
instagram that looks like some people
like that and that's it
we'll get back apologies about that what
about your reaction when you called up
that lady and
she said sorry it's sold and you were
just like oh
so disappointed uh basically that could
have worked for a lease option agreement
yeah and uh i did drive past that
property before
and i said you know what i recognize
this property it was on
you always say go to oldest listed that
was the oldest listed
and it was on there for like a year and
a half so i thought this is
really going to work built me hope so
and then she said i changed my mind
and that's the thing sometimes when you
get overly when you when you
you know you might spend half an hour
doing doing diligence on a property and
you get all excited but you just need to
phone up because they could just say
it's gone
um someone said i want samuel to live
with me forever
i don't think i don't think i don't
think you would i don't think you would
it was a hard week
i was having a shatter basically come
back
i was so tired for like two days after
yeah so okay
what was your favorite part of the
documentary um david uh
i think the very end i don't want to
give it away but
the end was uh better than what i
expected and it's not what i expected so
it's uh
definitely the ending the ending what
would you say to someone that hasn't
watched it
definitely watch it because it can work
it can inspire people people think you
need money to get involved in property
you don't you've got
rent to rent lease options it's just you
do the training and implement it and
people procrastinate
i think guess what i picked up from
alistair he really
on the last boardroom really like give
it to me they kicked my ass basically
saying you need to do this and i said
we'll take has advice as a good thing
not a bad thing and
it worked yeah the deals are everywhere
and you just have to make the call and
yeah and the whole the whole documentary
you know you probably saw it yesterday
it was just very chilled
you know we just i mean i went to um
ireland
we got a rent around very chilled next
episode
probably not so chilled a lot to come
definitely watch next week's episode
what
next week episode is coming out on
tuesday are you not watched it no i i
didn't
i'd say what it's not even been edited
yet i haven't even looked at the footage
i mean
there's a lot to do but if you want to
see part two we're planning on putting
out next tuesday
comment below let us know you want to
see it smash the like button subscribe
to the channel i don't know anyone else
in the world
that does as many property challenges as
i do you know moving into people's
houses helping them become financially
free
starting from scratch and documenting it
so that you can see how it actually
works in the real world
um so yeah check it out subscribe
and david you're going to come back on
the channel for more right i'm going to
come back yeah i'm going to get david on
again so if you've got questions for
david comment then below as well
and i look forward to seeing you real
soon thanks so much peace out